okay good morning everyone welcome to my
talk protected encryption keys with a
jakku vault my name is Stephen horns so
rough agenda what we're going to go
through today so we can talk a little
bit about data breaches you do a very
quick high-level cryptography overview
so everyone's on the same page in terms
of cryptography or encryption they're
going to talk about some different key
management options are available to us
which will lead us into talking about as
your key vaults more specifically and
then we're going to go through some
different patterns and practices you can
use when using something like key vault
so first of all what sort of set the
scene by talking about the threat of
data breaches so there's an interesting
website here called breach level index
now there are security consultancy in
the US but I quite like their website
because they have these very big glaring
statistics up on the page which is quite
useful to show leadership and businesses
when you're trying to convince them to
take security more seriously so the
number at the top there indicates it
since 2013 and I think these are more
us-based statistics but they're still
kind of relevant and that there's been
13 and a half billion records stolen or
lost from companies since 2013 but the
sad thing is that number doesn't
actually yeah it doesn't surprise me
anymore the numbers are getting bigger
it seems to be getting bigger every day
the bit that does surprise me this is
bit down here but it says that only 4%
of these data breaches were considered
to be secure data breaches that's where
the data is encrypted so you know today
to get stolen from a company but it's
useless because it's all encrypted and
you can't read it so really the reason
why I go around doing talks like this
and a lot of my other sort of friends
and speakers go and doing security talks
used to try and get that number to
increase so if you look at some example
was here some sort of large companies so
at the top they got JP Morgan Chase or
huge huge banking organization lost 83
million records in a data breach
Equifax which is a credit referencing
agency lost nearly a hundred and fifty
million records in a data breach and
target you know the US supermarket chain
110 million myspace become surprises
even still laughing but apparently it is
lost 360 million records and so on so
these are quite big examples but it can
also happen so much smaller companies as
well it's also if anyone's familiar with
Troy hunts have I been poned websites
well if you're not familiar with it it's
a breach notification website where you
can sign up your email address and if
your email address appears in any
breaches you get notified so you can
change your passwords again there's some
interesting stats on here from some
other companies again myspace is on
their LinkedIn lost 165 million Adobe
152 million now a lot of these companies
that we all probably use every day so
look at some of the effects of data
breaches so to a company there's quite a
lots of sort of negative consequences
that can happen so you can have
reputation will damage the organization
that's very difficult to recover from if
your reputation becomes damaged that can
lead to a loss of sales which can then
mean you know customers switching to a
competitor and once someone's switched
on other company it's very difficult to
get them to switch back you can have
legal action from customers or other
companies so you know that's expensive
and time-consuming and as well as
compliance costs if you're in a
regulated environment so finance health
maybe even military in government's then
it can be a lot of compliance costs as
you get fines levied onto your
organization but also most importantly I
think is that you can compromise the
safety of your customers so if you look
at the effects on on an individual so as
an individual you're having your data
your personal data being lost now
certainly in Europe on the GDP are you
own that data it belongs to you so
something that belongs to you he's been
taken without your permission this can
lead to identity theft and impersonation
which could then also lead to a loss of
financial data or maybe even a loss of
money if someone's stolen your card
details and it could also compromise
your transaction histories on websites
so if you've been buying and selling
them you know maybe don't want anyone
else to know about that information can
be can be leaked which is quite bad
but the mindset I think we should all be
in is that data breaches are inevitable
they're very difficult to stop so it's
not a case of if you're gonna suffer
data breach it's more of a case of when
and I think that's a kind of healthy
mindset to get into you know you may as
an organization spend hundreds of
thousands of you know dollars or pounds
on you know network perimeter security
firewalls intrusion detection systems
and they're good
you know don't stop doing that but that
doesn't necessarily stop a disgruntled
employee in operations who maybe didn't
get his promotion that he wanted or she
wanted doesn't stop them from going into
a database and select starring all of
your data from the tables and company
into a spreadsheet and taking it out the
building a large proportion of data
breaches do happen from within inside
companies necessarily external breaches
so GDP are obviously for us is a very
big thing being in Europe
I'm not saying much about Europe come
from the UK so slightly embarrassing
we're supposed to leave today in God but
GDP are is a real big issue as well
because under GDP are as I said you as
an individual on your data the company
is just a custodian for it so lots of
big fines could be levied towards
companies so that kind of sort of sets
the scene around why you know things
like a jaqui volts or any kind of key
volt and cryptography is important we're
trying to protect our company's
reputation and we're trying to protect
our customers from having their data
stolen so to a very very high level
crypto overview just so everyone's on
the same level playing field so broadly
when it comes to encryption we have two
types you have symmetric encryption and
asymmetric encryption so with symmetric
encryption we have things like AES or if
you're having to deal with a lot of
legacy systems you may still have to
deal with DES or Triple DES although
that's not recommended first new systems
but the reason it's called symmetric is
because you have one key and you use
that to both encrypt and decrypt
information so that's why a symmetric on
the flip sides that we have things like
RSA and even elliptic curve which are
called asymmetric because we have a
mathematically linked public and private
key which is used for encryption and
decryption so if I wanted to send
someone some encrypted data using RSA I
request their public key
get their public key encrypt the data
send it to them then they use their
private key to decrypt that data so
they're the only ones who ever have
access to that private key so symmetric
encryption the benefits are that it's
very fast
it's very algorithmic in nature it takes
data splits it into blocks and performs
operations against it computers are very
good at that
but the downside to symmetric encryption
is that sharing keys is very hard and if
you've got this you know AES encryption
key how do I get it to one of you so
they're not gonna email it's here we
don't want to stick it on a file on a
server not gonna want to put it in a
database and you nope sticking on a USB
key doesn't sound like a particularly
good idea either
so getting that key to other people is
difficult whereas on the flip side
things like RSA and elliptic curve
because they had more mathematical and
how they work so they're based on
modulus arithmetic they were lot slower
for a computer to perform by an order of
magnitudes compared to say a yes but it
does make the key sharing system easier
because you put you share a public key
which anyone can have access to but you
keep your private key secret so there's
no compromising of the private key well
there shouldn't be any compromising on
the private key and traditionally in
dotnet if we're going to do some
encryption we might use classes like AES
crypto service provider for doing a AES
encryption and we write these things
like RSA crypto service provider for
doing RSA based encryption both fairly
straightforward to use but there's you
know definite advantages and
disadvantages it's a both system so
moving on from that sort of talking
about sort of key management and how do
we manage keys so yeah there's lots of
different options out there that we
could use I mean probably the worst is
this one where you just stick your RSA
keys in an XML file and stick them on a
server somewhere I've worked for two
companies now that have done this you
know turn up on the first date so where
do you store your keys alright on that
server indie drive oh so that's not very
good anyone can access the
server potentially within the
organization just take a copy of those
keys another method that's very common
is the use of certificates you know
certificates are very well-known very
easy to use effectively and they give
details about who the
certificates issued to and from and as
you see public key verification you can
install it directly onto servers or key
stores in Windows for example and you
know there are robust and proven
mechanism they don't really require any
involvement from the end-user so if
you're buying a particular piece of
software that uses certificates they're
probably just going to get installed
behind the scenes for you or you have
operations staff that all handle them
for you don't really require any
additional hardware although you can use
Hardware to store them they're easy to
manage and they're supported by pretty
much every enterprise system out there
Linux Windows Mac there will support it
but the next best option is using
something called hardware security
module so these are vacuumed out herbal
appliances that you were put in a data
center typically you'd have two of them
colocation in different data centers so
that the keys can be replicated between
the two devices I need to allow you to
do things like store keys and perform
encryption on device these devices are
typically tamper proof if anyone tries
to physically access the box
they'll be lights and radiation sensors
in there which basically make the entire
system shut down so you had to send it
back to the manufacturer so they're
designed to be tamper proof in the
course I use them as a way of storing
certificates as well so you want to put
private keys of certificates on there
that's typically what you can do with HS
evans as well but the problem with HSM
is traditionally there's been very cost
prohibitive so the companies I've worked
at they've used and we've all been huge
healthcare pharmaceutical companies or
banks because typically these devices
might cost anywhere from you know fifty
to eighty thousand euros per device so
then quite expensive but luckily for us
and Microsoft have reduced that cost for
us by hiring or buying lots of these
devices putting them in their different
regional data centers and then providing
an interface for us to access them so
whilst this talk and all the demos I'm
going to show are kind of focused around
Asia and key volts the principles kind
of in the patterns that we're talking
about kind of apply to any other vendor
as well so
AWS has the AWS HSN and kms services
there's the Google cloud kms as well
kind of offers similar features and
similar functionality so even if you're
not directly can use as your key volt
kind of the principles do apply to other
other providers so with that let's take
a bit of a look at Asha key volts so key
volt is a service that lets you
safeguard cryptographic keys and secrets
used by cloud apps and services and what
Microsoft have done is they've bought
lots of these devices this is the
thallus and shield connect hardware
security module not quite sure how much
these cost I think go on their website
to find out then a sales agent once it's
phony which to me says expensive so I
wasn't willing to have that phone call
but what Microsoft done is it provided
an abstraction over hundreds or
thousands of these they have no regional
data sensors so that we can use them for
a minimal cost which is great as Yuki
volt there's two configurations you can
set it up in it's called hardware and
software mode now the common feature
across both of them is that all of your
keys are always stored on the HSM
hardware so if you generate RSA keys are
always stored on the secure hardware if
you use the software configuration then
any encryption and decryption operations
will happen on compute VMS inside the
azure vm inside the a Jacke volt service
if you use the hardware configuration
when you set it up then your encryption
and decryption operations are performed
on the HSM hardware directly but there
is an extra cost implications doing that
so typical recommendation is if you're
using as your key volt for your dev and
test environments you might use a
software configuration because it's
cheaper to use but then for production
you might use the more robust hardware
configuration API wise there's no
difference in it it's just a little bit
different when you set up the key volts
so looking at some example costs so for
non key operation cc's things like
writing secrets which we'll go into in
more detail in a bit it costs free sense
free US cents per ten thousand
operations so if you writes ten thousand
will read and write ten thousand secrets
from the key Val
that will cost you three cents and
certificate operations will cost you $3
per renewal request and then a further
three dollars it's like three cents per
10,000 operations across both the
standard and premium and pricing tiers
if you're doing software operations with
encryption keys so you know by using the
compute V MS then for RSA 2048-bit keys
or cost-free cents per 10,000 operations
across both standard and premium before
using highest REM 3072 or 4090 4096 bit
keys you'll cost you 15 cents per 10,000
operations in the hardware mode this is
where all your encryption in the
encryption happens directly on the
hardware you can't use the standard
pricing to yetiz premium and there's
some additional cost so for every key
that you creates that's going to cost
you $1 for the lowest strength IRS a key
and then 3,000 cents per 10,000
operations and then if you use the
higher strength Keys there's a tiered
pricing model so it's about five dollars
first 250 keys and then the price sort
of goes down in a staggered tier so
there's some sort of you know example
highlight cost cost you change over time
so you always check the azure pricing
calculator when you're looking to use
any of these things but they kind of
give you an idea of the sort of level of
cost it is compared to what it would be
to buy one of these machines entirely
depends on OC so I'm gonna give an
example of a system I worked on an
insurance company which will give her
probably a better impression to that
because I guess the real answer is it
depends depends on what you build him
but we'll cover an example a bit later
so once the key goes into the key volt
it never comes out so once you generated
a key in there you can't then just copy
the key out the key volt it's in there
permanently there is the facility to
backup your keys in key volt but
Microsoft have encrypt them first before
they backup so you do have the ability
to back the keys up take a copy and then
restore them later
should you need to but those keys are
encrypted so you can't actually
directly access to key material so
setting up key vault is relatively
straightforward always the best place to
go is Microsoft documentation so the the
getting started page is down there it
does change over time so you always need
to consult the latest documentation but
broadly for setting this up with
PowerShell you would create a resource
group you then create your key volt
specifying the region the resource group
and if you wants it in hardware or
software or the pricing - and once
you've done that you have the ability to
create hardware software keys read and
write secrets and upload certificates so
if I'm a PowerShell point right it cut
off on the side of a screen there but
for my PowerShell points of view you
connect to your subscription create a
resource group and then you've got these
commands down here where you create the
key vault by giving it a name resource
group location and then you can give it
a SKU pricing SKU once you've done that
you can then access the key vault via
the standard portal just like you can
with any operational resource say let's
you look at what's happening over time
it lets you look at metadata for keys
and secrets and certificates so you can
administer it from that portal if you
desire so that's great you know a lot of
Microsoft services use key volts
directly behind the scenes to manage
encryption keys but what we want to do
is we want to access it from c-sharp we
want to code against the key volts so to
do that there's an extra step we need to
do so we need to create an authorized
application using Azure Active Directory
sounds worse than it is but effectively
this is going to give us an application
ID and a shared secret that you have to
present to the keyhole to use it there
is a better method for doing that a
little bit later sorry it seems a bit
icky having to provide credentials to
access to key volts there is an opera of
option we'll look at in a moment
effectively you have you create an
application in Azure ad you then have to
make a notes of the application ID which
is this thing here so that's effectively
your username I guess it's a good way of
putting it
then you have to make note of your
client secrets which is this value here
when you go on that panel it only shows
you the client secret once once you
viewed it once it won't show you it
again so you have to make sure to make
note of it at that point if you don't
you need to kill that application
creating new one and then you can assign
permissions for that application so you
can say whether applications allowed
certain you know read and write keys
delete keys write secrets etc okay so
once you've done that nope
yeah so it's something you've got some
different permissions you can set on the
left there is another thing you can do
so if you're going to be using things
like Asia app services or Asha functions
to deploy your applications in so you
can set up what's called a managed
service identity and what this means is
that you can points your applications
that manage service our density and that
handles the loading in of the
credentials when your application starts
up so you don't have to present the app
ID and client secret directly so if
you're doing that that's probably a
better technique to use some interesting
blog post there that talked about how to
set it up but if you're not hosting your
web api or websites on Azure app
services and then you have to present
the user ID or the application ID and
client secret from your application
okay so keys versus secret so keys as
you can imagine our encryption keys on
as your key volt they're asymmetric RSA
keys it can create but you can also
store things called secrets which we're
going to look at some demos in orbit
later so a secret is effectively a
sucker key value pair store that you can
use the key volt size so you can write
in secrets like database connection
strings database passwords API keys
which you can store in the key vaults
you don't have to store them inside your
config files which is quite a neat
solution so we're going to be playing
around with some code I've got all the
code available on github and get from
that address there
it's I've leased on the MIT license you
can do what you want with it just don't
blame me if it doesn't work but the
codes are there that we're going to go
through in a moment so if you want to
play around many stuff at your leisure
you can do when you set up as your key
volts you have to installed a new gate
package so Microsoft Azure key vault as
you can tell that's a Mac screenshot so
you guys don't know standard 2 compliant
so it's working dotnet cool which is
quite handy so let's look at a simple
hello world application for KI volts is
where we hope that the Wi-Fi holds out
for us so in the solution that you can
download from github I've got various
little worms sample applications in here
that you can play around with ignore the
fake key volt class that's just my
insurance policy in case the Wi-Fi gives
up and whilst doing the demo I've
basically I've replicated some of the
functionality locally before the key
volts doing just so I can get through
the demos so you don't need to worry
about that class that's just that's just
in case of Wi-Fi dies and it does
frequently happen got some helper
classes here if some methods I've
created so we have the ability to create
keys and delete keys encrypts and
decrypts
and getting set secrets then I've got
some sort of boilerplate code here which
I'm using so in this example I'm just
I've set up a temporary key vault which
I'll keep online for a little while so
if you do want to download the code over
the next week or so and just have a play
around but I have got a preset up key
but you can experiment with what you
don't abused except anyone else abusing
it I'll just have to delete it and set
up a new one this is that application ID
that we talked about this is that client
secret which I got from the portal
obviously if you are presenting these
directly they're not using managed
service identities you didn't need to
think about how you can have protect
these values sucker chicken and egg
thing isn't it you know at what point
does the security start one company I
worked at they had some self-signed
certificates that are loaded onto a
protected server and then we encrypted
these values using the keys in that
certificate that was how they got around
the problem okay so let's look at this
example here so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to create a key I'm calling it
Steven Hamas's key because it's my key
so we create it here then I've got some
simple a bit bit of data here just a
string then I'm going to encrypt it and
decrypt it on the key vault and then I'm
gonna delete my key afterwards just to
keep this particular instance nice and
tidy
okay so I'm cresting the key vault there
creating the the key there was a bit of
latency in doing that as party wasn't
about Wi-Fi here but also you know you
were having to go off to a key vault
which I've got set up in the US create
the key and then return the ID for that
key back too so there is you know a
performance penalty in using the key
vault but that gives us back a key ID
that's a bit hard to see but it's URI
there just refers to the key that I've
created it's just like a unique ID for
that key then I've got some days where I
want to encrypt so I'm going to clip the
string hello world and then going to
call out to the key vaults so I perceive
my key ID are passing the day so I want
to encrypt it's you have to convert it
to a byte away first so you need to play
around with encodings and stuff but
converting it to a byte array and then
I'm just going to call out to the key
volts a key volt client is their client
class that you call in their NuGet
package and return the result then again
I can decrypt it so this byte array here
contains all the encrypted data from the
key volts this one contains a byte array
of my decrypted data and then also need
to convert those into strings so that's
a base64 encoded version of my encrypted
data a bit difficult to read I apologize
and then we've got the decrypted data
there which says hello world so we've
encrypted it and then decrypted it using
the azure key vault in an azure data
center somewhere and then I delete my
key to state ID so that's kind of a
hollow world application of using key
volts to do a simple encryption
decryption operation
okay so with that let's look at a few
few little usage patterns around using
the key vole again a lot these patterns
kind of apply to AWS key manager and
Google clouds kms as well obviously
we're just looking at a specific Azure
implementation okay so we can look at
six different items so multiple
environments configuration of secrets
local key wrapping key versioning where
we can use password protection where we
can improve password protection using
the key volts and digital signing and
digital signatures so multiple
environments so it's quite common than
when you're developing an application
that you're going to have numerous
development tests UAT environments and
then production note typically we
promote our code through different
environments into production so one
thing you don't want to do you just have
one shared key vault and you use it for
everything because then you know
effectively you're making your
production keys available to your other
test environments so that's not a good
idea you don't want to do that think you
might want to do is you could have one
shared key vault the e use for your test
environments and then a specific key
volt for production that's quite a
common usage scenario or if you script
up your environments in all two males
would just have one key volt per
environment but the key thing is that
you never share keys from production
into any other environment you need to
keep that production only and keep it
locked down make sure your operations
staff securely lock that key bolt down
okay so configuration of secrets so
secrets are a maximum of 25k blobs of
text that you can store inside the key
volts now you don't have to create a
specific encryption key for these
secrets that's handled by a key volt for
you so the best way to think of is it's
just like a key value pair no sequel
database but stored in a specific
hardware so you everything's encrypted
for you typical things you might want to
install so database connection strings
you know it's never a good idea typos in
your config files so you could store
those in that API keys for party
services so if you use any third party
integrations and they've given you API
keys to access those systems you can
store those
'we securely readies cash connection
strings you know or just anything
confidential that you don't want to
expose in your source code or 20 user so
they really are it's not very handy
secrets are versioned as well so if you
write the secret or if you write a
secret with the same identifier twice it
will keep a version for you which is
quite handy and then when you retrieve a
secret if you don't specify a version
I'm real to give you the latest version
but you can specify previous versions if
you want so it might be saying that
could be useful in your application
design let's have a look at that so the
good thing is with magic evil a lot of
these things actually very easy to use
so I'm hoping you can help use it as a
way of proving to employers that this
stuff's actually quite easy to do you
know let's not push the security
features to the back of the project
let's think of them up front so all the
helper files in here are the same as the
previous projects so literally it's a
few lines of code so I'm going to create
a secret mary had a little lamb and then
I'm just going to retrieve it straight
away from the database from the key
vault
okay so that's my secret is now being
written into the key vault
so he's got the secret main with Steven
haunts his secret and the value is
Mary's had a little lamb but it could be
a database password now I'm just going
to retrieve it so I'm retrieving it by a
name Oh Steven haunts his secret and
then I get a string back with my secret
hidden there so that could be a database
password API key anything that you want
to keep confidential
okay so local key wrapping so he gets a
little bit more complex but not more too
much so encrypting and decrypting on
hardware security modules expensives
he's seen that when we made the calls
out to the to the key volt there was a
bit of latency in that operation
happening and then the reply coming back
part of that is because I've set up the
cheapest as your keeper what I could so
it's not gonna be as performant as a
what a production one might be but you
know there is a lot going on there
you're sending stuff over to a kevo
encrypting it sending it back so there
is a latency so what we want to do is
use a more hybrid solution so what this
means it will do all of our encryption
locally using AES because it's nice and
fast we can keep it close to our
application but then what we'll do is
our AES encryption keys will encrypts
using the hardware security module then
that means we can store our AES
encrypted keys in a database if we
needed if we want to because they're
encrypted with our essay on the key
vault
another good thing about this is it
means that if you imagine you've got a
Web API and you're going to decrypt
about 20 different items for example you
could go into the API you could decrypt
your AES keys and the key volts that's
one operation towards your caste and
then those remaining 20 operations you
just do with AES locally so you're not
incurring any financial cost with the
key volts because you remember most
operations are charged in batches at ten
thousand there's a good way of keeping
your hash your bill down as well
especially if you're running a very high
bandwidth system just like an example of
that again all the source codes
available if you don't have a play
around with it later date
so in here I've got another helper class
called AES encryption two methods
encrypts and decrypts takes a bite away
at the data on to encrypt a bytes away
of my key which I'm going to generate
and something called an initialization
vector saying that you're passing to AES
help kick-start the encryption on the
first block so standard AES code uses
memory and crypto streams inside but
effectively we pass some data in here
with a key in the IV we'll get a byte
array back with our encrypted data and
to decrypt it we pass in the encrypted
data to the key in the IV again run the
code and then we get our encrypted data
back out such as some AES helper code
that we're gonna use I've got another
method down here called generate random
number which generates cryptographically
secure random numbers in dotnet and I'm
going to use that to create my
encryption key and the initialization
vector so we're passing a length that's
a length few bytes so for our key it's
going to be fair to two bytes or 256
bits and then that will return a bytes
away if the desired length full of
random data okay so if we look at the
example then so what I'm going to do
first is I'm going to create a key on
the key volt just like we did in the
previous example and then going to
create an AES key so that's first two
bytes
50 bytes in length and then what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna send that key
that I've just created to the key volt
and ask it to be encrypted so at this
point here we've got an encrypted AES
key back now at that point I could go
store that in a database or you know put
it somewhere safe so if we imagine you
know sometimes elapsed so now maybe
we've gotten a Web API method that's
being called and we want to do some
encryption the encryption operation so
the first thing we need to do is we need
to recover that AES key we need to
decrypt it so we can use it so I'm
making a call out to the key volts with
that encrypted key and specify my key ID
that we created a little earlier and
that gives me a decrypted AES key and
from that point onwards you know I
generate my initialization vector and
then I can encrypt load
using AES so I have a message here that
says make a top-secret stuff it's a
string I converted to a byte array I
encrypt it
then I decrypt it straight away and then
I display the results or convert the
results that we can display it
so we can create the key create my a es
key that's two bikes and then I'm going
to go off to the key volts and encrypt
that key right so now I actually want to
use that key for something else so if
you imagine this is you know some time
later a separate web call to come in we
first of all decrypt our key create our
initialization vector then at this point
I'm going to encrypt some data but this
is all happening locally now so I'm not
calling out to the key volt so we're not
incurring additional cost with the key
volts and AES it's nice and fast when
Crypt my data and here we can see our
encrypted text you know to take my word
for it there's encrypted text in there
that's a bit that's quite small and then
you can see why if the cryptic
straightaway it says mega top-secret
stuff
so that's quite a neat trick so tiny
does it keep our costs down it means
we're using the performance and the
efficiency of AES locally that's going
to run nice and quickly but we're also
protecting that AES key using the key
volts which is quite a handy little
technique so an example where I've used
this fairly recently it's working for a
fairly newish startup as insurance
claims management company so we built a
system that's a software as a service
platform so it's our system that we
built and deployed but what we do is we
white label the system for insurance
companies if you've got companies like I
don't know an axe or Aviva
sign-ups use decides when their agents
log onto the the agents portal it's all
viewed in their colours and branding so
it looks at one of their systems and
when the claimants trying to resolve an
insurance claim they can also log into
their version of the portal when it
again looks like the insurance company
that they're a customer of so it's a
multi-tenant system with custom branding
so when we onboard an insurance company
the first thing we did was we would
create a master key for that insurance
company in the key volts so if you had
access for example or don't have any
insurance companies exist if we take
them with quite a key firm in the key
volt that then becomes their master key
but then what we would do is we would
use that key wrapping technique where it
also generates an AES key or a series of
AES keys for different purposes which
with encrypted with their master key in
the key vaults and we stored that key in
a database so the feature of our system
is there any personal identifiable
information for any of their claimants
we always encrypted those fields that
the record level in the database who is
using a combination of sequel server and
cosmos DB so you might have a record in
a database but their name address phone
number date of birth gender all that
sort of stuff are being cryptid
this is Bertie will he look like they've
got each tenant so you've got four
tenants for example each one's got their
own master key in the key vault and in
the database somewhere we'd have a
tenant ID so that's the ID that relates
to that particular company would have a
key ID which is the key ID that refers
to the key in the key volts and then
also in that table would have an
encrypted version of their AES session
key in actual reality we had triangles
for different AES keys we had for
different purposes for each ensure the
finish example is just imagine we've got
one what it's meant was that effectively
each of the insurance company's data it
auto is all stored in the same databases
effectively partitions using security so
if for any unfortunate scenario say
tenant ID or ten and one so it's a
freeze on for their key got compromised
in the key vault but quite sure how that
happened but if it did the exposure is
just limited to their data that could
potentially be decrypted because they
wouldn't have any of the other keys for
the other insurance companies so this
then obviously obviously advantages
where local encryption operations were
faster because we're keeping it close to
you know service very running our code
we've decrypt the keys in the HSM store
in memory so that reduce a lot of
network hops and latency with the key
vault which is good because it is quite
slow to use it also meant it's very easy
for us to rotate keys so each of these
insurance companies had different
policies about how often you had to
change master keys so broadly every you
know between 30 days and 90 days you had
to change those keys this technique was
actually quite useful for us so if we
imagine that we've encrypted all of the
customer data using just that one key on
the key vaults
if you then go and change that key
you're in a situation where you then got
to go and re-encrypt
all of the data in a database which is
not a nice task for someone to be given
to do but because we're using this kind
of surrogate key here that we've created
and stored in the database
if we went and changed the key for
tenant for the only thing we need to
re-encrypt is this key down here so we
don't have to touch any of the data in a
database which is quite nice so when we
actually had a very fast and a fish
and key rotation policy preaching
insurance companies there was quite low
risk because you know you just you just
re-encrypt this key here we're not
actually changing AES key
we're just re-encrypt Singh you okay so
key versioning then so we just talked
about the idea that we can change keys
in the key volt and then we encrypt
local keys in the database it's kind of
like the additional equivalent of
changing the locks on your front door
so the one we just talked through then
turn you know you might have version one
of a key you use that to protects an aes
key locally but then you might introduce
a new version of the key so I said you
only need to re-encrypt that one key in
your database which is quite nice
another area where these this before is
the idea of chord incremental keys in a
way this works is you might have key
version one and then you might have say
you know a whole load of records that
you encrypted key version one and then
when you change to a new key you don't
change any of this data here you just
start using that key from that point
forward in time that's called
incremental keys an example of where
I've used that before in a system anyone
familiar with PCI DSS payment card
regulations is that a thing in in
Denmark and say it's a series of
regulations we had to adhere to and it's
all about how are you protects customs
card betas of credit and banking card
data so we built what was called a card
token volts so it was a separate system
that ran on a separate network in the
organization and when customers provide
us with their debit card details or
credit card details we would store them
in this protected system so none of the
other systems could directly access it
so the way this works is we would have a
key and I'm reading crypt say for
example 1,000 cards of that key let me
get let me get to a thousand we
automatically generated a new key and
then we encrypted the next thousand
cards with that key and so on the reason
you do that is if any one of those keys
ever got compromised or stolen then
you're limiting the exposure of data
that can be decrypted down to a thousand
cards not millions of cards
that's just another example of where you
can use different key versions when you
write keys into the key vault they are
versioned as well so if you give it the
same name it does create a brand new
version of it so you can actually use
historic key versions if you want to if
you don't specify a version number you
just get the latest key back we knew but
not back I mean you've been encrypting
it does it with the latest key okay so
passwords so we all know passwords
aren't a particularly great thing but
they're kind of here to stay it's
probably one of the easiest ways for
customers to authenticate of our systems
so if you think about you know all the
different parts of our techniques are
out there we can all agree that
plaintext passwords are the work of the
devil and we never want to use them the
next best technique which people might
use is to use hash passwords anyone do
password hashing just straight password
hashing not that many that are people
are willing to admit to it so you know
that's been used quite a lot but it is
susceptible to brute-force attacks where
you just try a billions of combination
since he get the correct hash or you
could do a rainbow table a dictionary
table attack which is a pre-computed
multi-gigabyte list of passwords and
hashes as the example website here crack
station Nets you paste a sha-256 hash of
a password in the top there and it all
tell you what the password is next best
technique is salted hashes so a salt is
where you generate a random number a
random piece of entropy that you append
on to the password and then you hash the
password of those two values you do have
to store the salts but basically what
you're trying to do is make dictionary
tables and brute-force attacks much
harder to do against the password
probably still one of the most common
ways of storing passwords in systems at
the moment does anyone do this
particular technique yeah a few people
so the next best one I apologize to the
emoji so then all I put these in there
the next best technique is C something
called a password-based key derivation
function or something like B Crips
sounds very complicated but really it's
not so in.net we have a system called a
password-based key derivation function
and what it is is a it's a password
hashing function so you put the password
in to one side you put the salt in and
then you give it a number of iterations
value and what is he's going to do is
it's going to repeatedly hash that
password depending on what that number
is if you put 10,000 in there it's gonna
hash to pass for 10,000 times and the
reason we do this is we're trying to
slow down algorithmically the password
hashing process because one of the
common ways of cracking passwords is to
use tools our hash Katz and powerful GPU
Hardware on your PC like gtx cards and
they can test billions or calculate
billions of hashes per second so if we
algorithmically slow down the hashing
process you can reduce that from
billions down to say 100 or 10 you can
do per second or passwords you can
attempt to crack per second so if you've
ever logged on to some websites where
you put your password and it feels like
you're waiting two or three seconds for
anything to happen chances are they're
doing an iterative password hash like
this and behind the scenes so in dotnet
is very easy to use there's a very
snappy named class called RFC two eight
nine eight derive bytes if you're
familiar with RFC specs is completely
obvious what it does but for most normal
people it's not so it's quite easy to
miss it so you pass in your byte array
if your password you passing the salt
and a number of iterations value call
get bytes and if you get the hash
password back the reason you return or
do you get by twenties because the
internally easy sha-1 not char 256 and
that returns a 20-byte hash code to only
need 20 bytes the higher the iteration
value the slower the hashing is going to
be and so I taught to workshop over the
last couple of days and we was playing
around with some of the different values
you put in there I think it put ten
million in at one point and it took
nearly ten seconds for it to generate
the hash
so of course you need to be careful what
number you put in there it becomes an
application design decision you know
what's an acceptable delay to wait yeah
if you think it's okay to wait three
seconds you might put a value of around
five hundred thousand in there it's kind
of a million in there be saying you have
to play around with okay it's up to you
you could mean you could have different
number of iterations values that you use
per customer or per class of user that's
entirely up to you okay so you'd think
we're good at this point you know
password-based key derivation functions
a recommended way of doing it it's what
i waas recommends partially we can use
the Kevon just to give us an extra
little bit protection when using a
technique like this so if we think of
the salts you know it's it could be
affected to by random number that were
generated so we could if we wanted to
use the local key wrap internally you
can actually encrypt the salts before we
store it in our database because you do
need to store the soul you have to
provide the same salt when you recompute
the hash so we could encrypt it and also
the number of iterations value you know
if someone's going to try and crack your
password they need to note that value is
now the security of a password-based key
derivation function isn't dependent on
keeping that value secret but probably I
want to advertise it either just makes
it a little bit harder so actually
storing it as a secret in your key vault
might be saying there's quite useful to
use a configuration item don't
necessarily want everyone to know what
it is
so one old story is a secret in your key
volt now there are obviously performance
implications to doing this so if we're
gonna cape calculator salts so we're
gonna calculate a password using this
technique and we've got two operations
to the key vault so you might decide and
this is what we did insurance company
that we weren't going to do this for
every single user where we encrypt the
souls and store the number of iterations
away but for people
and kind of like cps or admin access
into the system we took this extra level
of protection so as you can do quite a
lot of damage with their accounts so we
used it for a certain class of users you
know it's all there to make a potential
hackers life a lot harder and if they
steal your password hashing table if the
salts encrypted and they have no idea
what the number of iterations value is
you've just made their life a lot harder
which is good because ultimately we want
them to get bored and move on to someone
else and leave our company alone okay so
just look at a demo of doing that
all the codes here if you want to play
around with it so similar to the
previous example so I've got a class
here for generating a random number I've
got the password-based key derivation
function implementation here there's
just a few lines of code so it's not so
straightforward and I've got the key
volt the boilerplate helper code from
the previous examples so in this example
I am going to encrypt the souls I am
going to store the number of iterations
in the key vaults using that technique
we just discussed so are coming and I
create a key in the key volt agencies
ant was his self-contained so I create
new keys every time was he probably not
necessary to do that in your system so
create the key I then generate a salt so
I'm generating a fare to buy salt it's a
nice big long random number which I'm
appending to the passwords and crypt the
salt with the key volts and then I store
the number of iterations in this case I
said it's a 20,000 but I store that in
the key volt as well so now if we
imagine you know some time has elapsed
someone's trying to log on to the system
so the first thing we need to do when we
check their passwords we need to decrypt
that assault so we send the decrypted
salt to the key volt and ask it to
decrypt it for us we then call out to
the key volt and we say can you give me
the number of iterations value that I
need so that returns 20,000 there then
at that point we can just carry on with
the password hash as normal so let's run
that so create key
generate a local key or the the salt in
this case encrypt the salt
oops
helps if I were on the right project
doesn't it let's try that again
okay so create key crepe my salts
encrypt the salts with the key volt so
now we have in encrypted salts and then
we store a number of iterations in the
key volt so that encrypted so you know
we probably convert it to a base64
string and stored in a database
somewhere okay so now we want to check
our password so the first thing we need
to do is to the equip the salt for that
user we need to return the number of
iterations value back from the key volt
so for 1020 thousand maybe then have our
password which is password but I've come
and leave user numbers to change devours
a gate then we call hash password that
was a joke about the password before no
one laughed that felt a bit flat so I'm
not gonna have to password so we've got
our password as a byte array we've got
the salt of just decrypted and we've got
the number of iterations which is 20,000
I run it through RFC two eight nine
eight derive bytes call get bytes on it
and that returns us a password hash so
then what you do at that point is you
compare the value of that hash to what
you've got stored in your password table
if they match you know the users put the
correct password in they don't match and
they type the wrong password him so it's
quite handy little trick just to give
you that extra little bit of protection
around passwords I said you might not
want to do it for every user you'll be
incurring costs with the key volt but in
the example where I used it we had a
level of super users within the company
hours work and a hand within each
insurance company as well so we use that
technique for those people because I see
that they've got quite a lot of access
so we just gave them the extra little
sort of veneer of protection around
their password
okay so the final thing I want to talk
about then is digital signing and
digital signatures so in cryptography
broadly there's kind of four core
pillars to cryptography that we talk
about you've got confidentiality which
is what you know encrypting date so
making something confidential have
integrity which is what we use things
like char 256 for yes if you have some
data you calculate a hash for it
send update someone else with the hash
you recalculate the hash of a day to
compare them if they're the same then
you know that data hasn't been tampered
with when it's been sent authentication
we use things I can hash message
authentication codes so very similar to
hashing except you provide a key to the
hashing function so if you want someone
to calculate the same hash and somewhere
else they have to have that key to
calculate the same hash but then the
final pillow is called non-repudiation
and this is where we use techniques like
digital signatures before so a good way
of describing non-repudiation is to
think about contracts that we might
assign in real life so if you're buying
a house for example you might sign the
contract this solicitor someone
witnesses the contract so you know that
you're gonna buy the house for a certain
value if then later on you try and turn
around and say actually I want to pay
20,000 you know dollars less they could
say well no we've got this contract as
proof so that's what digital signature
is about it's about providing proof that
someone's done something and we use
cryptography for doing that
so our digital signature is a
mathematical technique used to validate
your authenticity and integrity of a
message software or digital document
it's an unheard of a service called
DocuSign yeah so DocuSign is a place
where you can sign electronically signed
contracts between multiple parties so
that you know if you then try to refute
what's in that contract later on they've
got digital proof that you sign that
contract exactly what digital signatures
are for a key vote let's just do that
quite simply which is really good so
when we do a digital signature there's
free operations that we need so we need
to be able to generate signing keys
we've already seen how to create keys in
the key volt so we've covered that
already you need a signing algorithm
this is where
passing some day - and you say crepe me
a digital signature of that data and
then you need a way of verifying that
digital signature later there's a
verification method when you pass in the
data in the signature if it returns true
you know that the signature is valid for
that piece of data it returns false then
you don't trust that signature typically
what you do is you would have some data
instead of creating the signature of
that data directly you create a hash of
that data first and it's the hash do you
create the signature for if you're doing
digital signatures yourself in dotnet
and the two classes you use are RSA
pkcs1 signature formatter and RSA pkcs1
signature D formatter so there were two
classes you'd use if he's doing this
manually yourself but luckily we don't
need to use those they're a bit of a
mouthful to try and pronounce so kevo
offers digital signatures natively so we
don't need to use that format of class
which is really good and as you can
guess it's probably quite simple to do
so let's take a look okay so in this
class I've got all the same boilerplate
stuff as before I've got a separate
little helper class here for doing the
sha-256 hash that's how you do hashing
in net you have a byte array of add a to
your to hash it called create a static
crate method on the sha-256 objects then
you just call compute hash on that
object that crates raw your hash code so
in the example here so again I'm
creating the cake so this is the keys
I'm gonna use for signing times what
we've done previously I've got a very
important document I want to sign in
this case is just a string but it could
be you know a PDF file or any kind of
file so I create a hash of that piece of
information so I converted to a byte
array in our hash it and we call that
the docket in digest that's the kind of
correct so and really it's just a hash
then what I do is I get that hash and my
key ID and I send it to the key vault I
call the sine method and what we get
back is the byte array of our digital
signature so you could then go and you
know basically for encode it store it
away in a database and then later on if
you want to verify that that digital
signature is valid for that piece of
data I you want to make sure that data
hasn't changed or no one has changed
contract you call verify you're passing
the hash of that data and the signature
will return true or false so just
quickly for a run it's giving an example
with where I've used this so in the
insurance system that talks about we had
two databases about a sequel database on
a cosmos database cosmos is a document
store so you can have objects in c-sharp
you can serialize him into JSON and you
just store them in that store so when we
settled an insurance claim with a
customer you know there's an interaction
between the insurance customer in the
claimants they've crashed their car you
know we know we know the age of their
car we know how many miles are on the
clock and we say okay your car is worth
five thousand pounds
the customer at that point says okay
that's fine I hit a button to say they
agree to the settlement then what we did
is we have a settlement document which
contains all of the information about
their claim in the final settlement
value and we create a digital signature
at XVII of that document we store that
information along with the signature
that we created in key vaults in that
cosmos dB so that's kind of like a
document that represents their claim
settlement so further down the line the
customer says actually no I want seven
thousand pounds not five and it's like
well now you hit accept and we've got a
digital signature that signing this
document that proves you said it was
okay to pay five thousand pounds yeah so
that signature gives you proof of that
document digital syncs has also valid in
many courts in a lot of countries so if
it ever went to courts and you've got a
valid digital signature for that
document that says you're gonna pay five
thousand pounds not seven that will
stand up in court that's kind of a
example of where we use this and as you
seen here it's just a few lines of codes
to create and verify the signature so
again we come in we create our key
I have my document which is just a
string in this case I hash out documents
and then I can call out to the key
vaults to sign the document so this by
trading is now my digital signature and
then I can go and verify that digital
signature and it returns true so let's
for example do that again let's create
the digital signature so let's now
change the hash so it's imagine that
I've changed the document and I've
recreated a new hash saw now you know
falsifying that document so let's just
change one of the values here so now
that hash isn't going to match with that
digital signature when I go to verify it
because I've changed a document I've
asked for 7,000 pounds instead of 5,000
so if we now go and verify their
signature on the key volt it's going to
come back and say false because we know
that that signature doesn't match the
data that we signed it with okay so
those are the six patterns I wanted to
cover I've been literally just about to
run out of time so let's do the summary
so we started off by saying you know
data breaches are inevitable they're
going to happen to everyone at some
point probably the numbers getting
bigger doesn't really surprise me the
bit that does surprise me is the fact
that we've got four percent of those
data breaches with secure data breaches
so we want that number to be higher if
your data get stolen from your company
you want data to be encrypted so they're
inevitable you need to get into a
mindset change if it's not if it's when
it's going to happen and to solve this
problem we've used as your key volts as
a way of protecting our keys and doing
RSA encryption on the key volts as well
Microsoft does like using the thala same
shield connects hardware so they've
taken the hit on buying these things and
I get a face if you rent them out to us
for not lots of money very easy to set
up so the all the key documentation
starts without address there there dr.
tation is actually pretty good for key
volt which is a which may to change
and we looked at six broad patterns so
multiple environments you said that you
don't want to share key vault instances
from production with other environments
you want to have separate instances
configuration secrets is about storing
secrets on the key vault so it works as
a key value pair store so you can store
database passwords API key securely on
the key volts to make your config files
local key wrapping was a technique where
we do AES encryption locally but we've
protects our AES keys using the key
vault which means not only do we have
faster encryption locally but we're also
reducing the number of network hops to
the key vault which keeps the cost down
key versioning as well so we talked
about the fact that you can using that
key wrapping technique it makes it very
easy to rotate keys and change keys
because you only have to re-encrypt that
AES key locally you don't have to
re-encrypt all of your data which is
quite nice
we looked at some techniques for
password hashing and we looked at the
part of a base key derivation function
but using the key volt we can go one
step further and we can hash out say we
can encrypt our salt values and we can
store the number of iterations value as
a secret if we want so it just gives out
that extra little veneer of security and
then we finally looks at digital
signatures and how easy they are to
create with the key volts so I've
covered quite a lot quite quickly if you
are interested in using this please feel
free to take the sample code and have a
play around with it each application is
completely self-contained so it should
be nice and easy to run the demo key
volt that I've created for this I'll
keep it up for money so you can use it
to play around we've provided nobody
abuses it starts sending ridiculous
amounts of keys to it I mean which case
I will have to change the credentials
but you know there's one there that you
can have a quick play around with if you
want you don't have to go and create one
just yet if you don't want to some
additional information so I've got a
course on protocol practical
cryptography and dotnet so if you want a
good IV over lock that dotnet and
cryptography classes that course is a
good place to start with and I've also
got a course called enterprise data
encryption we've as you
which took a higher level some of the
stuff we talked at today obviously we've
gone into more depth here if we insert
things like block chains I've done a
course called blockchain principles and
practices which is kind of like a
computer science class he talks about
how the fundamental data structures and
algorithms operate in a blockchain so it
gives you a kind of information about
what these things actually are so when
your CEO turns around and says I want to
blockchain you can actually understand a
bit more about what they actually are
and what they mean and I've also got a
book I've just released a very press
called applied cryptography and dotnet
so it's there if anyone finds that sort
fing useful so with that thank you very
much I think we're just on time so
[Applause]